for millions of his readers around the
world john le carre's work showed light
on a world of shadows in a writing
career spanning over
six decades likari authored 25 novels
and one memoir that came to define the
genre of the espionage thriller
it was art imitating life the first
three novels were written while likari
whose real name was david cornwell
was still working as a spy for the
british intelligence
his employers made him publish under a
pseudonym and he kept it for the
remainder of his literary career
titles such as the spy who came in from
the cold
tinker taylor soldier spy and the
honorable schoolboy
became cold war classics
likari's writings helped reshape
perceptions of that era
by portraying the treacherous antics and
moral ambiguity of the british and the
soviet spy agencies
after the end of the cold war he shifted
focus to the chaos of the us-dominated
world order
tackling issues from corporate
corruption and russian oligarchs
to extraordinary rendition and the wars
in the middle east
the themes are very relevant i think and
the the notion that we flood the world
with armies particularly the middle east
we never know where they'll end up we
don't know who the good guys are and the
bad guys
are good so i feel that i think that is
a theme we can
we can explore now as the news of his
passing was announced
tributes poured in from other genre
defining authors
on twitter horror and supernatural
fiction writer stephen king called
licare
a literary giant and a humanitarian
spirit
while the handmaid's tale author
margaret atwood said licari's novels are
key to understanding the mid-20th
century
in his last book published just last
year likari continued to draw on the
world around him
he brought the perfidy and deception
that's been central to his novels
into the world of brexit and donald
trump but in a life such as that of john
le carre
how much of it was fiction and how much
of it was true